welcome to get cooking in cloud where we
share the best recipes to apply in your
cloud kitchen I am Priyanka Vergara and
I'm stuffy Wong and in this season we
will share some recipes involving a
major networking ingredient cloud load
balancers so Stephanie what are we
cooking today today we are making
desserts YUM do I get to sample some at
the end I am a great dessert taster
tester taster either way sure if you
like dog food what yep because today
we're making dog treats
[Music]
[Applause]
imagine you're in charge of a complex
web site beyond treat your one-stop-shop
for vegan dog treats and it's an online
hit it continues to face high amounts of
traffic and you're not sure your website
back-end can handle the amount of
traffic from all over the world you know
you need to use load balancers but the
options are confusing I totally agree
without a recipe it can be hard to know
exactly how to settle on a load
balancing architecture that meets your
needs and figure out the prerequisites
you need for the best performance
without making much of a dent in the
wallet well to start you need to know
what load balancing is and why it's so
important to the long lasting success of
your application modern high traffic
websites serve hundreds of thousands if
not millions of concurrent requests from
users or clients and return the correct
text images video or application data
all in a fast reliable manner you've
probably all experienced visiting your
favorite website only for long wait
times connection timeout errors or
images and videos buffering and a lot of
the times this is because the website
backend is unable to cost-effectively
scale to meet these high volumes of
course the logical answer here is to add
more back in servers to help server
traffic but the next question becomes
how do you distribute traffic to those
back-end servers based on things like
capacity and health this is where load
balancing makes a splash load balancing
is the process of distributing traffic
across your network of servers to ensure
that the system does not get overwhelmed
and all requests are handled easily and
efficiently there are a number of
delicious reasons why load balancing is
important it lets you distribute load
balanced resources in a single or
multiple regions meet your high
availability requirements scale your
resources up or down with intelligent
auto scaling and use cloud content
delivery network for optimal content
delivery with cloud load balancing you
can serve content as close as possible
to your users on a system that can
respond to over 1 million queries per
second to decide which load balancer
best suits your implementation you need
to think about whether you need global
versus regional load balancing global
load balancing means back in endpoints
live in multiple regions whereas
regional load
pouncing means back and end points live
in a single region external versus
internal load balancing and what traffic
types are you going to serve they would
use external load balancers to
distribute traffic coming from the
internet to their TCP network and
internal load balancers to distribute
traffic within their DCP network the
external load balancing includes four
options the HTTP load balancing for HTTP
or HTTPS traffic the TCP proxy for TCP
traffic for ports other than 80 and 8080
without SSL offload the SSL proxy for
SSL offload on ports other than 80 or 80
80 or the network load balancing for TCP
or UDP traffic while the global HTTP
load balancer is for layer 7 traffic and
is built using the Google front end
engines at the edge of Google's network
the regional network load balancer is
for the layer 4 traffic and is built
using maglevs
Google and built maglevs in 2008 to load
balanced all traffic that comes into our
data centers and distribute traffic to
the front end engines at our network
edges the traffic is distributed to a
set of regional back-end instances I'm
not going to lie Stephanie my leave some
like delicious baked goods what makes
them so special
maglev was a break from traditional load
balancers and that it is software based
and operates in an active-active
scale-out architecture maglev evenly
distributes traffic over hundreds of
backends and minimizes negative impact
of unexpected faults on
connection-oriented protocols it's great
for lightweight l4 based load balancing
where you want to preserve the client IP
address all the way to the back and
instance and perform TLS termination on
these instances as for HTTP load
balancers I mentioned that Google pushed
load balancing out to the edge network
on front-end service as opposed to using
traditional DNS based approach so global
load balancing capacity can be behind a
single anycast virtual ipv4 or ipv6
addresses this means you can deploy
capacity in multiple regions without
having to modify the DNS entries or add
new load balancer IP addresses for new
regions so it's clear that with global
HTTP load balancing you get cross
regional failover and overflow and
distribution algorithm automatically
directs traffic to the next closest
instance with available capacity in the
event of a failure of or lack of
capacity for instances in the region
closest to the end-user we'll cover this
more in the next couple of episodes
GCB also offers proxy based load
balancers for TCP and SSL traffic and
they use the same globally distributed
infrastructure generally speaking your
decision to use them would depend on
whether you require SSL offload or not
you can find out more in the links below
now let's go back to beyond tree in
beyond trades case we are only going to
receive HTTP and HTTPS traffic so they
will choose HTTP load balancer but like
most companies the website also has
private workloads such as application
servers that need to be protected from
the public Internet those services need
to scale and grow behind a private
virtual IP that is accessible only by
internal instances for this their best
option is the regional layers of an
internal load balancing based on
Google's Andromeda network
virtualization stack similar to the HTTP
load balancer and the network load
balancer internal layer seven load
balancing is neither a hardware
appliance nor an instance based solution
and can support as many connections per
second as you need since there's no load
balancer in the path between your client
and the back-end instances over the next
few videos we will follow beyond treats
as they grow and even experience
unpredictable spikes in traffic like
when it's International Dog Day and Big
Bone treat orders are up the wazoo this
makes their website an ideal candidate
for explaining all the load balancing
options you have at your disposal but of
course you can apply these principles
described in these videos to a wide
range of workloads well there you have
it load balancing deconstructed my dog
is going to be so excited and he might
even make an appearance like Sam Wow
that's all for today on get cooking in
cloud we are hoping that you are making
the correct load balancing choice for
your architecture if you would like to
see more such content don't forget to
Like and subscribe to our Channel
you